[Musique]
c'est le paradis
quoi voilà donc on arrive devant
l'église notre-ame de l'assemption on
est au centre de de valoir on est sur
une architecture de montagne donc aspect
très sobre à l'extérieur là sur
l'extérieur et les travaux de de
confortement de l'église est-ce qu'il y
a des des choses à faire est-ce que tout
est ok est-ce qu'il y a du risque on le
sait sur certains bâtis religieux on a
des problèmes de drainage et
d'infiltration très important qui font
courir des risques à la structure tout à
fait là sur la façade principale donc
c'était les derniers gros travaux
d'intervention sur l'église voyez le
pied de mur est piqué il va y avoir un
drainage de réaliser pour que l'eau
[Musique]
s'infiltre
bonjour Émilie Bonivard je suis députée
de la 3e circonscription de la Savoie et
j'ai choisi de vous parler du patrimoine
religieux pourquoi je l'ai choisi parce
que avec 130 parlementaires nous avons
alerté sur le fait que ce patrimoine
était en danger parce qu'il s'écroule
parce que c'est cher de le réhabilité de
le restaurer et pourtant c'est notre
identité il fait partie des joyaux de
nots teroire de montagne ici mais du
territoire national c'est aussi la
beauté
l'esprit que l'on souhaite
[Musique]
sauvegarder lové dans les montagnes au
cœur de la Savoie dans la vallée de la
Morienne elle se dresse là depuis plus
de 900
ans des églises majestueuses aux Chapell
les plus modestes il y a dans la
centaine de communes que compte la
circonscription d'Émilie Bonivard plus
de 450 monuments
religieux la députée les républicains
est une enfant du pays d'aussi loin
qu'elle s'en souvienne ces édifices ont
toujours fait partie du paysage à croire
qu'ils sont
éternels il dénote une histoire très
importante celle de évidemment la la
ferveur des habitants de ces territoires
qui vivaient dans des conditions très
difficile et pour lesquelles la religion
à l'époque les les chapelles qui jent
chacun des villages donc on a de très
nombreuses chapelles et des églises et
bien était un lieu de de de refuge de
prière et de de pensé dans des
conditions de vie
difficile plus que des lieux de culte
ils sont avant tout pour la député un
héritage commun à préserver mais ses
chapelles et ses églises se dégradent un
peu plus chaque jour la parlementaire
nous emmène un peu plus bas dans la
vallée à une dizaine de kilomètres de
Chambéry tu as pris les clés de
l'église l'église de saint-joire prieuré
est classé monuments historiques malgré
la baisse de la pratique religieuse on y
célèbre encore des messes construite au
12e siècle elle a connu de nombreux
changements au fil du
temps avant elle avançait jusqu'ici ah
oui c'est ce que il' expqué et donc du
coup le premier transcepte a été démoli
de façon à pouvoir reculer l'église et
permettre le passage de quelque chose
qui était un chemin rural qui est devenu
une voirie puisquon est sur un ancien
passage romain d'accord
voilà c'est la première fois que je la
vois elle est elle est
magnifique celui qui accueille la
députée est Jean-Marc loutre il est le
maire de Saint
4 et donc l'enjeu oui de la partie
structure et conservation c'est d'éviter
que le poids de la charpente qui
commence à s'affaisser et de la porosité
de la toiture qui rend l'humidité qui
permet l'affaissement des poutres ne
viennent télescoper les croisés et donc
du coup que ça ça faesse ça
détériore depuis la loi de séparation de
l'Église et de l'État entretien des
lieux de culte construit avant 1905 est
à la charge des communes on en a la
responsabilité exactement comme de la
mairie exactement comme de la crèche
quand c'est une crèche communale c'est
la même chose donc du coup on est
propriétaire donc on a les charges du
propriétaire de la conservation de
l'évolution du respect d'un certain
nombre de pratiques à l'intérieur dans
nos territoires on a besoin de lieux
au-delà de la question cultuelle de
lieux qui sont beaux et qui parlent à
l'âme les travaux là ils vont pas se
voir terrible he en terme politique
c'est c'est tout ce qu'on aime pas faire
des choses qui ne se voi pas mais c'est
notre responsabilité
fondamentale mais cette responsabilité
pèse lourd dans une gestion quotidienne
déjà chargée pour les mares à laquelle
s'ajoute bien souvent un important frein
budgétaire à saintjoir préuret moins de
10000 habitants la réflection de la char
coûtera 2 million d'euros une somme que
ne peut absorber la commune seule il
faut donc qu'on trouve nous à peu près
une capacité d' de financement extérieur
50 % voilà de l'ordre de 1 million pour
que la commune ne puisse emprunter qu'un
millions donc 50 % et qu'elle l'étale en
remboursement en plan de financement et
là on est que sur du entre guillemets
service public non productif oui
aujourd'hui les communes peuvent
bénéficier de subventions mais mais à
condition qu'elle sacheent à qui
s'adresser et qu'elle parvienneent à
mobiliser autour du projet si je
caricature le maire de base il va dire
ma charpente ma couverture et le service
spécialisé va dire ce qui est normal
vous ne pouvez pas faire n'importe quoi
mais entre les deux il faut trouver tous
les ponts et toutes les translations et
tous les interlocuteurs pour accompagner
fiabiliser la décision et fiabiliser la
chronologie qui s'y attache et ça ça
prend pratiquement un dossier comme ça
prend pratiquement un mandat
mais d'avoir que que que l'État avec les
services des collectivités puisse mettre
en place des structures un petit peu
d'accompagnement ou des des personnels
qualifiés qui puissent accompagner les
maires soutenir les dossiers et les
demandes parce que effectivement le
niveau d'exigence qui est demandé à des
élus locaux qui n'ont absolument aucune
formation au départ sur ces sujets là
est extrêmement
[Musique]
élevé la députée milite pour un meilleur
entmun et qui n'ont pas tous leur église
classémilie Bonivard a rendez-vous à
Chen village de 800 habitants la
chapelle saintantelme sur plombe la
Valle bon mich bonjour madame la député
tu vas
bienie c'est gtil de nous rendre visite
cette chapelle du 19e siècle de style
néo byzantin est un bâtiment
emblématique du
village
ça fait partie de notre carte postale
moi dans ma jeunesse j'étais enfant de
cœur donc je venais faire ma communion
solennelle la retraite c'est ce qu'on
disait dans cette chapelle bien loin de
ses souvenirs d'enfance le maire
découvre une chapelle laissée à
l'abandon en très mauvais état donc on a
repris tous les décors pendant quasiment
8 mois on aura fait tous les plafonds
tous les tous les plâtres étaient tombés
on a refait tout à l'identique toute la
décoration
extérieure année après année pour lui
redonner son éclat 1 million d'euros
aura été déboursé et pour compléter les
aides publiques le maire décide en 2020
de candidater à la mission Stéphane
Berne son dossier est alors retenu un
coup de pouce bienvenu sur un budget de
300000 € Stéphane Bern la mission c'est
258000 € donc c'est quasiment la
totalité c'est vrai que ça demande une
mobilisation des élus et des
parlementaires parce qu'il faut qu'on
défende nos dossiers c'était un dossier
qui était pas difficile à défendre dans
le sens où il représente vraiment le
patrimoine savoyard il est au milieu des
vignes ouais c'est vra il est dans la
combe de savoix il est vu si c'était si
la chapelle s'était effondrée ça se
serait vu je pense que ça aurait fait du
bruitoui et donc je pense que ça a
motivé aussi la mission Berne en fait
aussi sur le côté intérieur d'être
associé à ce projet de la commune reste
que ce dispositif est limité cette
année-là sur 1500 dossiers déposé seul
Chinien a été
retenu alors comment aller plus loin
pour aider les petites communes en
septembre dernier Emmanuel Macron
annonce une nouvelle collecte nationale
une sorte de cagnotte solidaire pour
récolter 200 millions d'euros en 4
ans mais la solidarité des Français
pourra-t-elle être la seule solution à
la sauvegarde de ce patrimoine en péril
ce matin-là le maire de Valois amamène
la députée à 1500 m
d'altitude bonjour Bruno merci beaucoup
de votre accueil et de votre
investissement bonjour Bruno et Brigitte
habitent ici et ont décidé d'offrir de
leur temps libre pour préserver le
patrimoine de leur amameau la chapelle
du col est l'une des 17 de
valoir avant ces chapelles ell
rassemblaient que les chrétiens on va
dire mais aujourd'hui elle rassemble
au-delà elle rassemble des G qui sont
pas spécialement croyants mais qui rénov
il y a une dame qui me dit tu vois je
suis pas croyante mais c'est ma chapelle
je suis contente de la rénover et on
s'est retrouvé je sais pas combien au
MOS une V de bénévoles chacun ramène
quelque chose si bien que c'est vrai que
notre chapelle de temps en temps il y a
plus de bouteilles que
de allez on vous fait voir je passe
devant au fil des saisons il retape
rénov et entretiennent la chapelle pour
lui donner une nouvelle
jeunesse on a de la chance parce qu'il y
a un couple qui vient en vacances à
valoir ils ont une entreprise de
peinture dans le nord de la France et
ils nous ont fait un don de peinture
donc déjà c'était colossal donc avec les
bénévoles on a repeint tous les murs il
y a quand même trois couches cou et eux
ils sont venus le couple est venu euh
pendant leur temps de vacances pour
refaire tout ça donc c'est des bénévoles
c'est un don si vous voulez c'est un
mécéna c'est un M voilà d'accord ce qui
rassure un peu c'est de voir que ce qui
est notre bien commun notre patrimoine
commun et bien on se l'approprie tous
c'est pas que les élus c'est pas que la
commune c'est aussi les habitants qui
mettent la main à la patte et ça ça
montre l'attachement véritablement de de
nos concitoyens à leur
patrimoine à terme l'objectif de
l'association serait d'y installer des
expositions photos pour en faire
profiter locaux et
touristes à Saint-Jean de Morienne le
maire a lui décidé de faire renaître son
église au public depuis de
générations voilà l'église notredamee ou
super durant plusieurs mois les artisans
locaux ont travaillé des centaines
d'heures pour rénover l'église
Notre-Dame et aboutir à ce
résultat les mag y a
l'industrie le tourisme tu as le
ferroviaire et les fortifications il y a
qure thèmes qui se répètent chaque fois
autrefois sacralisé cette église est
transformée aujourd'hui en lieu de
culture 3 million et demi d'euros de
travaux avec un soutien important de la
région en terme d'équilibre économique
je suis pas sûre que on arrive vous
voyez avec même des événements privés
ici à amortir l'investissement qui a été
qui a été mis et pour moi c'est
important que on n fasse pas n'importe
quoi donc on peut désacraliser un bien
mais dans
l'esprit le fait que ce soit un notre
bien commun en terme de patrimoine
mémoriel c'est important donc une boîte
de nuit dans une chapelle
je personnellement je ne serais pas
d'accord évidemment rien n'est
impossible rien n'est
impossible une course contre la montre
est tout de même lancée selon un rapport
du Sénat d'ici 6 ans ce sont entre 3000
et 5000 gl qui
disparaîtront face à ce constat Émilie
Bonivard signataire de plusieurs
propositions de
résolution continuera à défendre les
42000 églises de France un record
mondial après
l'Italie